When knitters are first introduced
to knitting machines,
they're often surprised and  somewhat
disappointed to find out that we can't
create kKnit and Purl stitch
combinations as easily on the machine
a we can by hand.
The default stitch for flatbed
machines is stockinette.
Brother knitters can invest in a Garter
Carriage that easily produces
both knit and Purl stitches.
But not all of us have that luxury.
You can hand manipulate and reform
individual stitches one at a time.
This is practical for a small sections
of knitting, maybe one or two purl rows
here or there, but it can get a pretty
tedious for all over patterns.
Utilizing the ribber, we can
create both knit and purl stitches.
Although it's similar to reforming
individual stitches,
you might find that using the ribber
and transferring stitches between the beds
is worth the effort that it takes.
A let's walk through creating this
a popular checkerboard stitch
pattern on the machine.
And decide if it's worth the extra
time.
Caston both beds and set your machine to "P"
so that the needles line up
directly across from each other.
It'll make it easier
to transfer the stitches.
Now be sure that when you arrange your
needles, the sets of needles
that you're transferring
are lternating. In other words,
you don't want needles to be
crashing into each other.
Once you hang your cast on comb,
arrange your needles in groups
of six. On the main bed, six needles in work
and six needles out of a work,
alternating across the bed.
Set the ribber needles in the same
manner, alternating with the main bed.
6 needles in work, 6 needles out
of work. Then knit for eight rows.
Next, transfer the ribber
needles to the main bed.And
the main bed needles down to the ribber.
And knit eight rows.
Repeat this sequence for the length
of your knitting to create
the checkerboard pattern.
You can do the transferring of stitches
between the beds by using your double-eye
needle one at a time
from one bed to the other.
Or
try using a three-prong transfer
tool to make the transfers.
Remove three stitches on the tool.
Carefully transfer the three stitches
to a second three prong tool.
And then deposit those
stitches on the opposite bed.
Once you get in a rhythm,
it really isn't too difficult.
I found success by first holding
the first tool in my right
or my dominant hand.
Remove the stitches,
then I switch the tool to my left hand
and use the second empty
tool in my right hand
again to make the transfer.
See what works for you.
But for me, this method was a much faster
than transferring the stitches one
by one with a double-eyed needle.
Mistakes are going to happen. With all
these transfers back and forth,
you're bound to drop stitches.
Don't panic.
It's always a best to pick up the dropped
stitch from the row below and hang
the stitch on the bed where it started.
That way, you can repair the stitch
and be sure not to split the yarn.
Then continue the transfer
with the picked up and repaired stitch.
Snd you're back in business.
Another thing to note is that some brands of
a standard gauge machines have
an accessory called a transfer carriage.
Again,
not all of us are a lucky enough to own
one, but if you do, this might
be a good time to dust it off
and try to create this
reversible checkerboard pattern.
Can you start to imagine
more possibilities
in mixing up the transfers
of the knit and purl stitches?
Either way, it's your call. Transfer
the stitches,
or a walk away from the machine,
pick up your hand knitting
needles and get knitting
Happy Knitting